I don't want our memories to ever fit
into a
box. I want a
lifetime with
you. There should be a mass
fullblown boycott. Bro, let me tell you
something. If you know anybody on
Salams, say to him, bro. Say salamlay to
him.
Brothers and sisters, it is the winter
season in the UK. Today in my house, my
boiler broke and the house was freezing
cold. My kids are wearing jackets. I'm
trying to find heating and as a father,
I'm trying to make sure my kids, my wife
are warm. Imagine the people around the
world. I'm working with one of my
brothers 100% donation policy charity
who are helping Syria, Lebanon, and
Afghanistan. People who are freezing to
death intense brothers and sisters.
Donate whatever you can because today's
experience with me showed me subhan
Allah how vulnerable we are and just
made me remember those people who are in
need. Whatever you donate guys, even if
it is £1, help those people in those
countries.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
salams. You about to say salam. You're
going to say salamlaykum to salams. All
right. Yes. Yes. What is this? That's
Yeah, it's it's salams. So, we're going
to be talking about salams app. Yeah.
So, did you know the salams app, which
is a matrimony site? Yeah. Yeah. So,
which they say salams to people. Yeah.
Salam to the people that didn't believe
in me. Yeah. Yeah. But this one, we
don't believe in them. Okay. Because
they've sold the company with 6 million
users to how many? 6 million. No way.
Yeah. Okay. Nice. So 6 million users,
Muslim users, alhamdulillah, using this
and it's been sold to a Zionist.
Yes. And apparently this has only been
exposed via the Q report, i.e. it wasn't
clearly in it wasn't clearly mentioned
to their followers. Yeah, this was
something that was found out by certain
people. And not only is the person just
a Zionist, he is actively supporting the
genocide that's taking place. Um, and I
don't know how comfortable the users are
knowing. I think I don't think they
know. I don't think they know. They
they've apparently said that they
received no emails telling them about
this transfer, etc. But what we're going
to do is we want as many Salams members
to say salamlaykum to the app. Yeah.
Yeah. Yes. Yes. I think if you have any
shame whatsoever, you will not only
boycott the app, you will delete the
app, eviscerate it from your
Yeah. And and spread this far and wide.
You know why? Because this app is very
popular. Let's watch some videos of how
they used to promote it. Yeah. Let's
watch it. Yeah. It's the
same. Um it's a bit tense right now. He
seems hesitant to speak to my
mom. Let me call you back.
[Music]
I hope you like my gift. It's a bit
cliche. I know. I know.
But so is
love. Can you
imagine how far we come?
from that first salam to well
yeah
Fatima I don't want our memories to ever
fit into a
box I won't a
lifetime with
[Music]
You marry me.
One second, bro. That sounds That's
sounds buiy, brother. What is that?
She's coming home and saying he doesn't
want to speak to my he doesn't want to
speak to my mom. And now she's saying
that. So she's speaking to two people at
once. I don't get it. She doesn't want
to speak to my mom. Some see it like a
dating app. Some see it like a Muslim
matrimonial app. But the bottom line is
that any app that has accumulated data
of Muslims and the thing is that they
need to be responsible. Yeah. If you're
now going to sell it to somebody else,
let your users know so they can make an
informed decision because we don't want
Muslims to acquire data and then
tomorrow if they're going to sell out
then give it to some Zionist guy and
then slowly go out the back door. That's
that's very snaky behavior, bro. That is
to me, I'll be honest with you. Like
talking about the app looks I don't
know. I don't know much about the app.
Yeah. But from that ad, I mean that
interaction that girl and that guy is
having I don't know. First she was like,
"Oh, he's not speaking to my mom." Yeah.
That's a red flag, sister. Yeah. And
then I don't know if that's another guy
and then she's speaking to another one
who's sending something with a video and
saying a mama and dad's talked, etc. I
don't know what's going on with the app.
Yeah. So, um, again, the point is this.
Yeah. Is that put that to a side about
being halal, haram? Can you find someone
from there? That's all difference thing.
The point is this. Yeah. You've got like
6 million Muslims who are using this
app. The point is this, bro, man. If you
could sell it to anybody like how cold
you have to be or how I don't know what
you're on that you go you can't you
cannot come and tell me the owners of
Salams cannot come and tell me oh we
sold it to a company we didn't know no
no no brother please this is a
transaction you sold it for hundreds of
millions if not in the billions region
maybe maybe and you have to tell the
people that another company brother
forget that bro if if it's like bro if
like bro you're snaking someone on a
level and then on top of that you're
going to the worst people like Zionists
these individuals who are massacring
men, women. And this guy, you can see,
look, for example, I don't know if
you've seen this, bro. This is what he
had to say. You know, he's been feeding.
Look, look at this. Yeah. The guy
Spencer Ruskov. Yeah. See your match
group. This is the comment that bought.
Yeah. Proud to
support Ohana and Co. Whoever
co-founders of Jacob Ian Halbert and
Ezra Gian campaign to help cover rent
bills for Israeli soldiers fighting
overseas. You can earn you can learn
more and support their campaign. So why
they go? It's like they're going to
commit a genocide and I'm like, "Okay,
I'll cover your rent. You know, it's PK
people. You go do your thing. I'll got
you covered." Yeah. Bro, it's as good as
me used to point. It's as good as me
giving you a gun and a bullet, which
you're going to massacre people. And
then you go using if if it's owned by
Muslims. We're making an assumption
here. I'm sure it's owned by Muslims. I
don't know. And then you go and sell
that to a Zionist, full-blown Zionist
that is paying for the rent of these
Zionist IDF dirt bags and Muslims. There
should be a mass fullblown boycott. Bro,
let me tell you something. If you know
anybody on Salams, say salamaikum to
him, bro. Say salamlayum to him. So I
believe this is something that the
Muslim um has to be warned against and
they need to feel the full force. I
mean, if the only good assumption I can
give about the Muslim owner is this,
I'll sell it to the Zionist owner, get
his money, um give it to the
Palestinians, whatever, and then let the
people know it's owned by Z.
The only thing I could see is because
you got 6 million people who uh firstly
obviously there's 6 million of them and
those individuals now their data has now
been compromised their pictures their
information you know sensitive
information you don't put any other you
got your height you've got your
preferences you've got what you do
you've got interactions back and forth
I'm sure there's a a chatting or this or
that function I don't care about none of
them
bro I don't care about look you I don't
care about high you forget that right
now your funds are going to support
Zionism bro that's the worst thing about
it look that information is very
important don't get twisted but I'm
saying right now I am active it's like
going to Starbucks I say no I'm going to
go Starbucks I'm going to Starbucks bro
and you know what it's sad because the
users have been snake and backstabbed
because now the funds are going to
someone they don't even know it's like
me going to I'm bo I go to another cafe
that is owned by Starbucks I don't know
about it I'll be angry I'll be angry so
they bro sayamlaykum salams
Alamulaykum. Boycott them. Yeah.
Full-blown. Share this far and wide.
It's your duty to share this far and
wide. Boycott. Make sure they go bust.
Bro,
how's your fishing? It's good. I like
fish. Yeah. Yeah. Do you like those
fried fish? Masala fish? Yes. They're
nice. Yes. With tarta sauce. A good
source of omega-3. Yeah. I need I need
omega-3 for my eyes.
On that note, bird's eye view. Oh,
nothing wrong. I thought it's fish. No,
it's going to the bird's going off to be
with the fish. Yeah, guys, please let me
know how my hat looks. In the meantime,
I'm sorry. I was just a joke. Was it
bad? Oh, okay. Oh, all right. Listen.
Are we still friends? Oh, guys, I need
to talk to him. Bye-bye. Salaamikum.